you've probably heard of placebo effects
this is when we can feel better after
receiving a fake treatment like a sugar
pill
for decades Placebo effects have been
discounted as irrelevant to the field of
Medicine
but now we know better
Placebo effects are real and in some
cases they are more effective than
expensive drugs
unlocking how Placebo effects work has
been one of the more remarkable findings
in recent decades and it may be the key
to a revolution in medicine
hi I'm Joe Merchant a best-selling
science author and in the next 30
minutes I'll take you through some
stories that are so full of surprises
it's hard to believe they're true
We Begin now with a woman who fractured
her spine and he was only able to find
Relief by undergoing surgery
[Music]
let's start with a true story it's about
an older woman from Minnesota named
Bonnie Anderson
in 2005 she slipped on wet kitchen tiles
and fractured her spine
after the injury she suffered severe
chronic back pain when I interviewed her
she told me that because of the pain she
couldn't stand up to do the dishes or
play golf which she loved and then she
found it hard to sleep
desperate for Relief Bonnie took part in
a trial of a promising new surgical
procedure called vertebroplasty
with this method surgeons inject medical
cement into the fractured bone to
strengthen it
the surgery often seemed to dramatically
improve back pain within a few hours
with many patients returning to normal
activity within days
that was true for Bonnie too she told me
it was wonderful it really took care of
the pain I was able to go back to my
golfing and everything I wanted to do
a decade later when I spoke with her she
was still delighted with the outcome
Bonnie's fractured spine was apparently
healed
but here's the twist in the story
for surgery Bonnie received was fake she
just didn't know it
her surgeons acted out the whole
procedure
they gave Bonnie a local anesthetic read
from a script and even opened a tube of
the cement so that it smell like nail
polish remover filled the room
and they pressed on Bonnie's back to
simulate the placement of the needle
but she never got the injection of
cement
and she wasn't the only one there were
131 patients in that trial overall their
Pain and Disability scores were cut
almost in half with some like Bonnie
showing dramatic Improvement
remarkably there was no difference
between the patients who got the
vertebroplasty and those who just
believed they did their belief it seemed
was as effective as the surgery itself
cases like this raise important
questions when we're ill can positive
thoughts emotions and expectations make
us better
can they stop us from getting sick in
the first place
these are controversial issues on one
side there are many claims for the power
of mind-body therapies often from
alternative healers these range from
easing pain and fatigue to downright
miracle cures I've seen claims from
regenerating limbs using pure awareness
to diffusing emotional conflict to cure
cancer
the idea seems to be that the mind can
heal just about anything if we start
thinking more positively
fighting back against this position are
the Skeptics often conventional doctors
and scientists they dismiss any idea of
healing thoughts as deluded and often
attack not just the claims themselves
but any attempt to even investigate the
subject
one skeptical biologist described
research on the mind-body connection to
me as rubbish Tooth Fairy science and
even morally offensive
another called it for academic medicine
asking why would actively doing nothing
have any active physiological effect
so there are very strong feelings on
both sides of this debate and perhaps
that's not surprising because the stakes
are high
some Believers are so convinced of the
mind's power that they go far beyond the
evidence and people who desperately need
medical treatment can die as a result
yet determined Skeptics attack any
suggestion that the minds might play a
role in health meaning that we may miss
out on what could be a powerful force in
medicine
so who's right in this series we're
going to investigate both positions and
explore whether our minds can heal us
here's where I stand I'm a science
writer with a PhD in genetics and
medical microbiology and I believe that
the Medical Treatments we put our trust
in should be tested in rigorous trials
but I also think we should pay closer
attention to the links between mind and
body
we all know from experience that our
thoughts emotions and perceptions affect
our bodies and do every day
if you step out into the road and are
almost hit by a car you feel a jolt of
adrenaline and your heart starts to race
you can get turned on just by hearing
your Lover's voice and feel a sense of
Awe by looking up at the night sky or
wretch violently at the sight of maggots
in the trash
in researching my best-selling book cure
a journey into the science of Mind Over
body my aim was to take an open-minded
but evidence-based approach to what the
research really says
can the Mind influence physical health
if so how might it work what can the
Mind do and not do
to answer these questions I spent
several years tracking down researchers
doctors and patients involting
cutting-edge studies and trials all
around the world
my goal was to explore how the mind
influences the body and how we can use
the latest discoveries in our own lives
I'm still on that Journey as new
evidence comes to light
in this lecture series we'll look at how
the mind can influence the symptoms we
experience and how it can affect the
physical progression of disease
we'll consider how thoughts can shape
our health in crisis moments and
throughout our lives we'll investigate
whether meditation really makes us
healthier and discover astonishing ways
to fight disease
we'll also assess the limits of the mind
and the dangers of untested therapies
and I'll share my personal experiences
from being burned in a virtual reality
Ice Canyon to visiting the religious
sanctuary of laws
by the end I hope I will have empowered
you to understand the role all of us
have in our own health
[Music]
let's start by considering Bonnie's case
how could fake surgery fix her painful
back
this is an example of a well-known
phenomenon called the placebo effect
where people often feel better after
receiving what they believe to be
effective medical treatment even if that
treatment is fake
as strange as it might seem placebos
from sugar pills to simulated surgery
can apparently benefit patients across
many different conditions and types of
treatment
this effect is the reason why new drugs
and treatments are always tested against
a placebo
the purpose is to make sure that any
benefits are due to the treatment itself
and not for other reasons
but it has traditionally been assumed
that the placebo effect itself is either
a statistical blip or a delusion
the argument goes that if someone feels
better after a fake treatment then they
would have improved over time anyway or
maybe they just think they feel better
or say they feel better when nothing has
actually changed
back in 1954 an article in the
prestigious medical journal the Lancet
stated that placebos simply Comfort the
ego of unintelligent or inadequate
patients
even today that perspective is quite
common
the placebo effect has been described as
a myth a failure or my favorite the beer
goggles of medicine it's often seen as
something irrelevant if not downright
harmful a contaminating effect that can
fool us into believing that treatments
are effective when they aren't
from this point of view the placebo
effect is the very definition of
something that doesn't work if a
promising therapy can't beat a placebo
as thrown out
and yet while statistical effects and
eager to please patients are responsible
for some of the improvements recorded in
medical trials they're not the whole
story not by a long way
there's now a whole field of research
showing that something else something
big is going on when we believe in a
treatment
so let's dive into Placebo effects how
and why it is receiving a fake treatment
sometimes make us feel better
[Music]
let's begin with what has been described
as the moment that the biology of the
placebo effect was born
Placebo effects themselves have been
known about for centuries but in the
1970s scientists discovered naturally
occurring substances in the brain that
ease pain
they're chemically related to opioid
drugs such as heroin and morphine so
they were called endogenous morphine or
endorphins for short
this was the first hint that the brain
is capable of producing its own drugs in
fact morphine and other synthetic drugs
work because they mimic natural
endorphins binding to the same receptor
sites or neurons to block pain related
signals in the brain
the discovery of endorphins caused a
neuroscientist named John Levine to
wonder whether placebos might work in a
similar way
in 1978 he performed a crucial
experiment on patients recovering from
dental surgery
he gave them an intravenous infusion of
saline salt water that they thought
contained morpheme a third of the
patients reported experiencing
significant pain relief even though
they'd received no drug it was a classic
placebo effect
then without telling them Levine added
to their IV drips a drug called naloxone
which blocks endorphin receptors the
patient's pain returned
in a second experiment he gave them
hidden naloxone first before they
received the saline that time they
reported no pain relief at all
this was remarkable
what Levine had shown was that you could
block the placebo effect with the drug
naloxone
this proved that the pain relief wasn't
just in the patient's minds they didn't
imagine it their belief in the treatment
activated the same biochemical pathway
that morphine would have
it was the first study to show that
Placebo effects worked through
measurable biological mechanisms
whole new understanding of placebos was
born
in one sense perhaps it shouldn't be
surprising that a thought or belief can
produce a physical effect
but the idea that a belief could create
a medically significant outcome similar
to that of a drug was and still is
difficult for many to accept
it means that if someone is given a
placebo and feels their pain belt away
it isn't necessarily trickery or wishful
thinking they're not weak gullible or
unintelligent or inadequate patience
their pain is easing through the same
biological mechanism as when they take
pain killing drugs
since Levine's groundbreaking trial and
particularly since 2005 or so thanks to
advances in brain Imaging techniques a
huge amount of researchers further
investigated the role of endorphins and
Placebo effects
neuroscientists can now look inside our
brains and see what happens when we take
a placebo
studies using positron emission
tomography pet scans reveal a drop in
available opioid receptors when people
experience a placebo effect proving that
those receptors are being used
functional magnetic resonance imaging or
fmri scans show reduced pain related
activity not just in the brain but in
the spinal cord too suggesting that
placebos can turn down pain signals even
before they reach the brain
Levine's work inspired another Pioneer
in this field to study placebos
his name is Fabrizio Benedetti and he's
a neuroscientist at the University of
Turin in Italy
Benedetti has shown that you don't even
need to take a placebo to experience a
placebo effect our beliefs modulate our
symptoms when we take real drugs too
he's tested this by getting people open
versus hidden infusions of painkillers
in these studies some people know
they're getting the painkiller others
don't
for example in patients recovering from
surgery he either told the patient they
were getting the drug or he just added
it to their IV chip without telling them
Benedetti found that a whole range of
potent painkillers were far less
effective when people didn't know they
were getting them to achieve the same
level of pain relief patients who didn't
know they were receiving the drug needed
a 50 percent higher dose and some of the
drugs didn't work at all
it's just the same with painkillers you
might take at home
the relief you feel is the combined
effect of two components the direct
biochemical effect of the drug plus the
effect of your belief in that drug both
Pathways activate the same receptors in
the brain
[Music]
another of Benedetti's key findings is
that there isn't just one placebo effect
there are many
what he means by this is that a placebo
can trigger various different responses
in your body depending on the
circumstances
in one study when patients who had
previously received morphine later
received a placebo painkiller it
activated their opioid receptors
but when patients had previously
received a non-opioid painkiller that
works by activating different receptors
in the brain called cannabinoid
receptors receiving the placebo
activated those receptors instead
this shows the placebos can work through
at least two different neurochemical
Pathways depending on previous
experience and expectations
in other medical conditions there are
different mechanisms again
Benedetti has researched placebos for
Parkinson's Disease which affects the
nervous system
Parkinson's patients have Tremors and
trouble controlling their movements
because of a lack of the
neurotransmitter dopamine in part of the
brain
Benedetti and others have shown that
when these patients take a placebo they
experience a flood of dopamine just like
when and sometimes as large as when they
take a drug
Benedetti is also researching altitude
sickness in a lab he built high up in
the Alps where the oxygen level in the
air is just two-thirds what it is at sea
level
to get there you have to take three
cable cars from the nearest ski resort
out of the window well you can see a
snow-capped Peaks for Miles oxygen
deprivation at this altitude can cause
symptoms such as headaches dizziness and
nausea
I visited Benedetti when he was carrying
out tests on a volunteer named David
I watched David working out on a step
machine while Wireless electrodes
attached to his scalp monitored his
brain activity and senses on his chest
tracked his Vital Signs including heart
rate and blood oxygen levels
after 15 minutes of exhausting exercise
during which his oxygen levels dropped
David continued stepping but he was
given supplementary oxygen to breathe
or at least he thought he was
in fact Benedetti had tricked David and
me the oxygen canister was empty it was
a placebo David wasn't breathing oxygen
after all just normal air
in this study Benedetti compared the
performance and physiology of two groups
of volunteers at altitude those who
received the placebo oxygen and those
who didn't
overall the placebo group suffered fewer
symptoms of altitude sickness and their
performance on the stepper improved
Benedetti found that this effect also
works through a measurable biochemical
mechanism
not surprisingly the amount of oxygen in
the volunteer's blood didn't change
but those in the placebo group had
significantly lower levels of chemicals
called prostaglandins in their saliva
which are produced when oxygen levels
are low
these induce a variety of physical
changes such as dilating blood vessels
to help pump more oxygen around the body
they're also thought to cause the
headaches dizziness and nausea of
altitude sickness
so these are just a few examples of how
beliefs can affect our biology
in fact our brains have an entire inner
Pharmacy of molecules like endorphins
cannabinoids dopamine and prostaglandins
that regulate our physiology and can
create or ease symptoms many of the
drugs we take piggyback on these
pathways
what these studies of placebos in pain
Parkinson's disease and altitude
sickness show is that our minds can
influence these processes too
[Music]
one reason that Placebo effects haven't
been taken seriously by many scientists
until recently is because they are
Elusive and changeable they're hard to
pin down in scientific studies
we've heard how in different situations
placebos can trigger different effects
and mechanisms
and the proportion of people who respond
to placebos varies too depending on the
circumstances it can range from zero to
a hundred percent in Trials of one ulcer
medication 59 of a placebo group in
Denmark felt significantly better but
only seven percent did in Brazil
the exact same Placebo can also have
positive neutral or even negative
effects depending on what we're told
about it
all of this is contributed to the
conception of placebos as dodgy and
unscientific with results that don't
seem to make sense
after all there's nothing in a placebo
so how can one Placebo be different from
another how can nothing be different
from nothing
but this is looking at placebos all
wrong
by focusing on the fake treatment we're
getting distracted it's a hangover from
the Western idea that you need a
physical drug to have a physical effect
The crucial Point here is that any
change that occurs has nothing directly
to do with the fake treatment how could
it placebos have no active ingredient
instead what matters what triggers the
biological change is a person's
psychological response to the placebo
what receiving that treatment means to
them
and this can be influenced by lots of
things
one key factor is expectation how do we
expect our condition to change or
improve
this is different for everyone and
depends on many factors such as what
we're told about a treatment how
optimistic we are in general whether we
trust the doctor and our mood
previous experience is also important in
other words Placebo effects can be
learned and even boosted
if a particular drug has helped you
before and you take a placebo that looks
just like it then that past experience
can strengthen your positive expectation
for the placebo creating robust effects
that can sometimes work as well as the
drug itself
the characteristics of a placebo can
also make a difference to our
expectations in general anything that
conveys the impression of a potent
effective treatment evokes stronger
Placebo responses
studies show that big pills work better
than small ones brand name pills work
better than generics two pills work
better than one and the more we pay for
something the greater the placebo effect
for the same reason invasive or
elaborate treatments like Shams surgery
or acupuncture tend to trigger larger
Placebo effects than simple fake pills
we can see a nice example of this in a
recent meta-analysis that's a study that
combines the results of lots of
different trials
this one included more than 5 000
patients being treated for migraine and
it compared the effects of the various
different placebos used in the trials
compared to no treatment
patients who received what they thought
was Botox injected into their head
reported the largest Placebo responses
the next best was the intravenous
injection of a fake antibody
Placebo antibodies take an orally or
injected Under the Skin also worked but
were the least effective
another big factor in the success of a
placebo is social interaction Studies
have shown that regardless of what a
treatment is the human aspect of care
makes a surprisingly big difference to
how patients do
one trial looked at people with
irritable bowel syndrome who were all
given the same simulated acupuncture
this is a placebo version of acupuncture
where the needles are inserted in the
wrong places and don't fully penetrate
the skin
these patients had significantly greater
relief from their symptoms when their
practitioner was warm and empathic
compared to when they were cold and
polite
another study of acid reflux disease
found a similar effect this time people
received either a homeopathic remedy or
a placebo there was no difference in
outcomes between the two but the length
of the appointment made a big difference
after a 20-minute appointment 17 of the
patients said their symptoms were at
least halved but after a 40-minute
appointment in which the therapist
listened to the patient talk about their
condition that figure soared to 75
percent
the importance of care is something
we'll examine later in this course
[Music]
so in what conditions do placebos work
best when might our expectations help us
to feel better and when should we be
heading straight for conventional drugs
and surgery
well in general Placebo effects seem to
be strongest at modulating the symptoms
we experience they are very good at
influencing how we feel
that means they are particularly
effective for pain from The Chronic
joint pain of arthritis to the acute
Agony of a burn victim as well as things
like nausea fatigue itching and wheezing
large Placebo effects are seen in
psychiatric and developmental disorders
including depression and autism
placebos can affect cognitive function
memory and sleep
what can placebos not do
well there's little evidence that they
alter the underlying physical
progression of disease
simply believing that we've received a
beneficial treatment doesn't influence
how a medical condition might take hold
and develop in our bodies
for example in Parkinson's disease
placebos temporarily ease symptoms but
don't fix the underlying problem in the
brain although I should point out that
neither in this case to the drugs
one study with asthma showed that a
placebo helped patients to breathe more
easily but it didn't change an objective
measure of their lung function and
there's no evidence that placebos can
lower cholesterol banish a serious
infection or influence the progression
of a tumor
remember Bonnie Anderson with her fake
surgery
the placebo she received vanished her
Pain and Disability but it probably
didn't mend her spine
these are key limitations Placebo
effects aren't an all-powerful
protective magic that can keep us well
in every circumstance they only work in
particular situations
but that doesn't mean they have no value
for medicine in fact easing symptoms is
a hugely important part of modern
Healthcare think about all those
painkillers and antidepressants we take
so if placebos can help this is great
news because conventional drugs are not
very good at treating symptoms like pain
fatigue gut problems and depression
what's more some of the drugs we
commonly use for these conditions can
cause significant problems of their own
from side effects and addiction to how
much they cost
[Music]
some of the benefits of placebos large
enough to be worth chasing
yes well there's lots of variability
placebos often rival drugs and their
effectiveness
in Parkinson's disease researchers have
reported up to a 50 reduction in
symptoms about the same as a dose of the
drug apomorphine
meanwhile a recent study treating
itching in patients with dermatitis
compared to Hidden drug dose in other
words a drug but no belief with a
placebo a belief but no drug the placebo
worked better than the drug
more broadly many drugs believe to be
effective are turning out to work mainly
through Placebo effects in 2008 the
Harvard psychologist Irving Kish used
the Freedom of Information Act to force
the U.S Food and Drug Administration to
share clinical trial data on
antidepressants
the data showed that apart from severely
ill patients antidepressant drugs such
as Prozac had little effect over and
above a placebo
more recent analyzes have confirmed this
meanwhile the Italian neuroscientist
Benedetti whom we met earlier found that
Valium which is widely prescribed for
anxiety disorders has no effect at all
unless patients know they are taking it
an evidence for the power of placebos
continues to accumulate
a recent meta-analysis of different pain
interventions including 215 clinical
trials and more than 40 000 patients
concluded that the placebo effect
accounted for about 75 of the overall
effective treatment
in other words only 25 percent of the
patient's pain relief was linked to the
biochemical action of the drug
three quarters of the relief was due to
patients belief in the treatment
in the United States the placebo effect
in clinical trials of painkillers seems
to be getting even stronger perhaps due
in part to Consumer drug advertising and
the fact that trials are getting longer
and more expensive
both of these factors boost patients
expectations for the drugs they receive
ironically this also means it's getting
harder for drug companies to get new
painkillers approved because they must
show that their drugs perform
significantly better than placebos
in 2013 new painkillers tested in U.S
clinical trials beat placebos by just
nine percent
these are the best new experimental
treatments the big Pharma could come up
with
patients had dramatic reductions in pain
but almost all of it was caused by their
minds
why that de placebos work so well
why can thinking that a particular
change is going to happen often make
that change come true
understanding this opens up a whole new
way of thinking about our bodies and our
symptoms and points towards how we can
harness placebos without fooling
ourselves both in medicine and in our
own lives
we'll talk about these issues next time
I hope you enjoyed this sneak peek of my
new series The Power of Mind Over body
if you'd like to learn more about all
the ways that our minds can influence
our bodies and health be sure to stream
the full series now on wandrium
[Music]